maeva guéna djeddah dammam ayvaz gars
là papesse de la télé réalité puisque
maeva gainey a fait une boulette même
temps on n'est pas une boulette presse
et sa mère s'est pas amer
qu'a fait la boulette mois en fait elle
fait boulette sur boulette alors qu'elle
a fait une faute au regard des noms
alors ah ça c'est mal grec alors voilà
c'est vrai en fait derrière si vous
regardez bien derrière la personne est
en fait tenu
longtemps qu'elle est un peu cette nuit
habite bon et des mois parce que je ne
sais pas de quoi se
défend jean
d'amour et qui s'en veut énormément la
place lancement à culpabiliser parce que
c'est sa fille et qu'elle voit la cccc
dur pour elle l a fait cette photo elle
a posté dans la précipitation faut dire
aussi qu'elle était dans un moment de
deuil aparté après il y avait un
enterrement et s'était pas très bien
alors but fait pas très deuil comme j'ai
pas de sa maman était en fait elle a pas
elle est sortie en vitesse et elle n'a
pas réfléchi à la fin pas regarder la
pab héritiers elle a posté sa vie ça m'a
fait il est vrai qu'en général maeva
guen avant on peut pas dire qu'elle soit
tout le temps très habillée dans queen
on
vous explique moi après ça quand ça
s'est passé moi ma et val m'a appelé
tout de suite elle était en crise elle
hurlait de tristesse et toute la faute
aux attendes la photo a tourné de
partout à bailleul et en fait quand on
s'expose et qu'on est qu'on a envie de
montrer une partie c'est une chose mais
quand
ça va aller
toute la journée je suis d'accord avec
vous mais en fait il ya le fait de
diffuser ou plutôt bien il fait de
montrer non c'est vrai c'est pas la même
chose et c'est vrai qu'elle est plus en
plus mal fait un gros travail en ce
moment justement pour arrêter pour
essayer de grands enfants de grandir
c'est une gêne pas s'arranger penderie
j'ai passé un bep en fait taxées elles
c'est vraiment salah ça lui a fait mal
au coeur est venue à paris il allait
chez moi en ce moment parce que ça va
vraiment touché revel est venue à paris
elle est allée à l'âme alors on a
des vidéos de maeva qu'étant qui est
d'ampleur regarde les nerfs
s'il vous plaît pensez même pas la faire
tourner ou quoi la photo
c'est une vraie dame ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attendez je n'aurais pas ça parce que le
respecte comme je respecte
à droite wade petit chien a envie d'être
et à la droite
et a pu le dire çà - doit
et comme c'est comme tu as des cov avec
les mac and staff c'est vrai que on
comprend la tristesse qui est la sienne
ah non mais ce mais je crois qu'il
s'exprime ça fait rigoler et là c'est
vrai que la halle est en larmes c'est
pas non plus la mort du petit cheval
mewes temps que j'attends j'adore ma
mais bon ça arrive c'est une gaffe de
5,4 va très bien et passons désavantage
opus la photo elle et on la voit elle
est loin c'est le feu louis et dire
arrêtez de faire tourner la photo
malheureusement elle sait très bien que
c'est impossible qu'à partir du moment
où ces procédés le monde a capturé
elle n'a pas demandé à ce que cette
photo est sa plus basse est vrai que
c'est pas dramatique c'est une guerre
une erreur tu m'en fait pas ni de la
faute de sa mère sarah qui arrive à tout
le monde en redemande est un spécialiste
de la reine mère qui rapport à ça c'est
parce que bertrand deckers depuis le 5
minutes je vous le dis qu'ils pensent
qu'il est au zoo
alors là il va guy
roux c'est alors j'invite mes retrouve
ce soir mangez shabbat à la maison il y
aura maeva c'est avec moi alors là et
lucky douche avec maeva gainey ça peut
être sympa je veux bien avoir fait une
vidéo est ce qu'on va manger des
boulettes
sacha roi super g et en europe la guerre
donc oui savourer sans voir que
l'univers celle une femme voilà c'est
l'univers qui pose problème pour moi
c'est pas vous imaginer la même histoire
en angleterre le prince charles est
prête pour ça il ya ça me fait asseoir
alors ça ne risque pas d'accuser n'ont
pas causé une univers est différent la
culture est différent la vue on a vu des
petits laharie tahri on avait tenu un
des jarrets ouais ben hammam est ce que
c'est une période de
la vie en voyez vous une photo de votre
pénis comme ça oui souvent sans excès en
dehors de mon pays ni non j'ai mis des
photos de moi nue elle va j'ai envoyé
des photos de moi oui voilà à la
mauvaise personne non
[Rires]
je viens pas de doute
parce que des fois
tout moment et on va passer à autre
chose mais j'ai en voit rarement mon cul
à des inconnus voilà c'est prêt c'est
votre expression que mon cul je passe
mon temps à montrer son bateau à suffire
est exhibitionniste reconnaissait le
mans vous aimez savent mettre à poil et
alors on héros non non non pas du tout
peut-être tout un poil dans cette
émission c'est mon métier la fesse ses
lecteurs c'est l'acteur et l'acteur wii
mc et des ouï dire en tout cas si je
peux me permettre moi je sais que maeva
salle affecte beaucoup et je voulais
faire un gros bisou l'on n'en boit
efforts et que les gens l'aiment
beaucoup et c'est une fille sensible et
c'est une vraie fille c'est une vraie
fit sensation il faut le dire à madame
monique c'est vrai
mais le show attendu un mois et puis le
choix d'apparaître comme chargée dans la
libre parole mois se jouer là j'ai
l'impression que je suis au musée grévin
aller alors on va puisqu'on parle de
musée grévin non j'ai vraiment dit ouais
moi il ya quelques années mais je dis
pas quand parce que voilà il ya quelques
années j'ai fait un live sur instagram
pour parler voilà et en fait c'était en
été et s'était pas en confinement même
où on est un peu en pyjama ou ont fait
paraître au gabon en l'occurrence
j'étais en robe et c'est vrai que
j'avais pas mis de sous vêtements parce
qu'en fait il faisait chaud et tout
machin est donc je fais mon live j'étais
sur mon lit et tout j'ai fait mon live
je les poster et ensuite mon meilleur
ami il m'a envoyé une capture d'écran il
me dit c'est incroyable on dirait
vraiment et carrie ann en dessous pas
j'avais des jambes et je regarde ça et
je fais j'étais même pas au courant je
regardais chez et du coup j'ai supprimé
mon live donc non t'inquiète c'est
vraiment une erreur d'image c'est trop
drôle et tout donc personne n'a jamais
rien su lui il l'a vu et peut-être que
d'autres personnes sont posé la question
et c'est moi je les ai vus à l'est
et
c est ce qui est bon pour notre édition
de jeudi 30 là le 30 émissions qui
mettrait bien oui mais est-ce que vous
êtes mieux sous la robe
ont du coup maintenant anne marie alors
on a la vidéo me dit dans l'oreillette
de du live et instagram
6,6 après s'est bien passé c'est pour ça
écoutez vous écoutez bravo